[Música]
y llega el momento de hablar de las
noticias de la salud de la mano de Mara
Romero sala Mara Un saludo para usted
Buenos días Ángela y no es ninguna
sorpresa hoy dedicamos este segmento a
hablar de las mujeres uno de los temas
más comentados en estos meses mar es el
derecho al aborto particularmente en
Estados Unidos si vamos a dedicar todo
el espacio a digamos una lucha un
problema y una figura referente y
alrededor de las mujeres pero empezamos
con esto porque ayer llegó la noticia de
que son cinco mujeres que han denunciado
al estado de Texas Texas al Haber puesto
su salud en riesgo por no permitirles un
aborto lo antes posible o de forma
digamos rápida especialmente después de
que la corte constitucional revertiera
Robert sus wave en Texas solo se
considera una de las consideraciones del
aborto es cuando la vida está en riesgo
es decir la persona gestante tiene que
estar en riesgo de muerte para que se
acepte el aborto y Estas mujeres hablan
de que tuvieron embarazos deseados pero
que por complicaciones de salud no
podían llevarlos a término no iban a ser
viables y los médicos no podían hacer
nada hasta que realmente la condición
llegara a ser tan insostenible o tan
grave que realmente las como las
comisiones éticas de los hospitales y
del Estado les aceptarán la interrupción
del embarazo además también una de las
cosas que denuncian es que los médicos
están con miedo de dar recomendaciones
al respecto no recomendaciones alrededor
de la salud en la interrupción de un
embarazo por miedo a ser sancionados
amantes duraski es una de las
demandantes y daba uno de los
testimonios escuchamoslo
significaba que aunque iba a perder a
Willow con certeza mi doctor no podía
intervenir mientras su corazón todavía
la tierra
en minutos pasé de estar sana a
desarrollar sepsis una condición en la
que las bacterias de la sangre provocan
una infección que puede matar en menos
de una hora
absolutamente indignante absolutamente
indignante Ángela los orígenes del 8 de
marzo mar están en las reivindicaciones
laborales de las mujeres el campo de la
salud No es una excepción Sí el 8 de
marzo empezó no como el día de la mujer
trabajadora lo comentábamos antes y en
el campo de la salud sucede algo que es
que el 70% de la fuerza del trabajo son
mujeres que además trabajan por cierto
con una brecha salarial del 28% de uno
de los campos laborales en los que hay
más brechas salarial en la que estás más
grande porque como siempre las mujeres
están normalmente ocupando situaciones o
posiciones consideradas más bajas por
ejemplo la enfermería que es esencial
pero que suele tener salarios inferiores
a puestos directivos que siguen estando
ocupados mayoritariamente por hombres y
esto sin reconocerle eso que al final la
gran mayoría y la inmensa mayoría de los
trabajadores de salud que están en
contacto directo con los pacientes son
mujeres pero es que esto no termina así
sino que hay varias denuncias de que en
medio de los sistemas de salud formales
no informales dentro del trabajo formal
hay millones de mujeres que trabajan sin
cobrar especialmente en países en vías
de desarrollo no el valor del trabajo de
las mujeres en el campo de la salud se
valora en tres billones de dólares pero
en la mitad de este trabajo es fruto del
trabajo no remunerado el informe de
woman in global Health Calcula que en el
mundo hay al menos seis millones de
mujeres que trabajan sin cobrar o
cobrando muy por debajo de lo que
deberían sobre todo Estamos hablando de
trabajadoras voluntarias de la salud
comunitaria por ejemplo cuando hubo el
19 las mujeres que voluntariamente se
programas para ir a convencer a la gente
de que se vacunara en las comunidades
rurales no es un ejemplo de este trabajo
que desarrollan imprescindible que
desarrollan las mujeres indispensable no
reconocido y sobre todo no remunerado no
tendría que ser un secreto en 2023 que
las mujeres impulsamos las economías de
los países haciendo trabajos de cuidado
que no deberían ser gratis pero que
todavía lo son en la mayor parte de los
casos sobre eso le quiero hablar más
allá del trabajo formal las mujeres
también nos encargamos del cuidado de
salud de nuestros familiares claro es
decir más allá incluso de esta de este
no reconocimiento dentro del trabajo
formal hay todo ese trabajo digamos que
le han mal llamado doméstico que sucede
dentro del seno de las familias o de las
redes de afecto y que es un rol de nuevo
imprescindible para cuidar de la vida y
de la salud de las de los pacientes de
las personas que tienen problemas de los
hijos de los padres de los suegros no
que muchas veces recae sobre las mujeres
hay unos datos que trajimos aquí de la
fundación Kaiser se son relativos
únicamente a Estados Unidos y que
básicamente muestra esa responsabilidad
de las mujeres dentro de la salud de los
hijos no el 70 o sea a la hora de
seleccionar qué personal médico va a
tratar los hijos el 79% toma la decisión
únicamente la mujer se sucede algo muy
parecido a la hora de llevar a los hijos
a citas médicas o de asegurarse de que
los hijos y las hijas reciben los
cuidados que les han recomendado los
doctores del único lugar en el que
empieza a parecerse algo relativo a un
Equilibrio es cuando se debe cuidar a un
hijo enfermo Aunque sigue siendo 40% de
las veces las mujeres lo toman como una
responsabilidad propia no en este caso
es verdad que el cuidado conjunto toma
un poco más de relevancia entre los dos
progenitores pero como vemos sigue
habiendo una desigualdad palpable y un
trabajo que pues dicen que es amor que
también pero que no deja de ser trabajo
sobre todo alrededor de la salud No y
cómo no y en las relaciones de pareja
mar Cuando el hombre gana históricamente
más que la mujer pues sé quién es menos
grave que pierda días laborales por
cuidar a un hijo pues es un pez que se
muerde la cola terminamos hablando de
una referente en el el campo de la
medicina y de la salud la primera mujer
que ganó el premio Nobel de fisiología Y
esto es muy importante Sí pues para no
quedarnos únicamente en esas cosas que
son malas o que son tristes o que
deberíamos denunciar hablamos de gerty
es la mujer que nació en la Praga en una
familia judía que posteriormente emigró
a Estados Unidos a raíz de la
persecución nazi y que todo tuvo toda
una vida de lucha por el reconocimiento
no siempre estuvo un paso por detrás a
pesar de haber ganado el premio Nobel
por ejemplo no la hicieron profesora de
su universidad hasta que hubo ganado un
Nobel No eso que hacía falta por cierto
en 1947 que fue cuando los galardonaron
para poder acceder a la misma posición
que la que tenía su marido cori con
quien ganó precisamente el premio Nobel
lo ganaron por descubrir uno de los
mecanismos por los cuales el cuerpo usa
energía tienes el nombre de la pareja el
ciclo de Cory básicamente es que cuando
hay un ejercicio muy fuerte y el aire no
llega suficientemente a los músculos el
cuerpo usa un mecanismo como de
reciclaje no se usa el azúcar para la
energía se convierte en lactato en los
músculos y luego este lactato pasa por
la sangre hasta el hígado y allí los
recicla de nuevo el cuerpo otra vez en
azúcares para que los músculos lo puedan
volver a aprovechar y quería terminar
escuchando precisamente Cómo habla esta
mujer gerty Core una pionera de la
investigación sobre el trabajo
científico escuchémoslo
como investigadora los momentos
inolvidables de mi vida son esos que
llegan después de años de trabajo arduo
cuando el velo de los secretos de la
naturaleza se levanta de repente y lo
que parecía oscuro y caótico se muestra
en una luz Clara y hermosa gracias a
usted Por eso y ya para el cierre para
esta fecha siempre de los hombres
tienden a darnos regalos que a veces son
inapropiados cuál es el regalo que usted
quiere del día de la mujer Pues miren
nunca voy a hacer esa persona que le
diga que no al chocolate pero la verdad
para el día de la mujer a mí me gustaría
que pudiéramos tener esos derechos y que
se reconocieran precisamente todo este
trabajo que hacemos extra y que
normalmente sigue siendo invisible
Muchas gracias más gracias Ángela